what can I do for you sir um mouse I'm
looking for a car something sporty
something sexy well then do I have the
perfect vehicle for you it's a Porsche
Spyder super high-end great track speeds
heads will be turning when you take this
baby out on the road ha boy Oh fantastic
though be warned it is an expensive car
we're talking close to a hundred K for
this baby I said I'll take it price is
no object I see great I'll just ring it
up right now
you clearly don't understand I said I'll
take that spider and I'll take it for
free if I need to out buy up every other
car dealership in the area just to put
you out of business that spider will be
mine for $0 and you know what you'll be
glad about that I'll show it off
alongside all my other cars and you will
love it you'll eat it up you won't be
able to get enough as I sell you the
privilege to watch me show off all my
cars are we still talking about cars
I'll make millions billions off that
free spider okay so would you like
roadside insurance with that hello
Internet welcome to film theory not
owned by Disney yet but we are available
so last time well last time we talked
about Disney's other star attraction
Elsa but the time before that we talked
about spider-man and whether it makes
sense for Disney to outright buy the
movie rights to the character as well as
all the other 900 characters that he's
associated with all away from Sony
Pictures for the pool pool price of five
billion dollars ultimately concluding
that yes it's a deal that makes a
surprising amount of sense
despite that figure being higher than
what they paid for the entirety of the
Marvel and Star Wars universe is the
long and short of it was that they would
get greater creative control over how
the character gets used while also
making more profit than they're
currently getting in their current deal
with Sony he becomes the leader of the
New Avengers big villains get their own
standalone releases allah venom minor
characters and villains get their own
Disney Plus shows everyone sells a whole
lot of merch and Disney finally earns
enough to knock down the Hollywood sign
and rebrand the entirety of
as Disneyland it's just now the whole
southern half of the state of California
however at the end of the episode I
alluded to one key sticking point this
will issue the possibility of Disney
getting spider-man for free why pay ten
or even five billion dollars for
something when you can get the biggest
discount in history and just walk away
with it all for the low low price of
zero billion dollars you don't even have
to clip any coupons or use your honey
browser plug-in for as crazy as that
might sound it's actually within the
realm of possibility so join me today
for an episode of film theory all about
game theory the economics concept a
prisoner's dilemma played at the
mega-corporation scale with billions of
dollars and thousands of jobs on the
line and all of it is centered on that
darn webhead now up to this point in our
analysis we've been talking a lot about
what spider-man is worth to Disney but
it's equally important to consider the
value of Spidey's film rights to Saudi
cuz if we're being honest sony needs
spider-man big-time six of Sony's top 10
highest-grossing films worldwide are
from the spider-man franchise over 50%
it is undeniably the studio's biggest
property without spider-man Sony's next
biggest properties are James Bond pretty
solid and then Jumanji I mean don't get
me wrong the new Jumanji movies are a
heck of a lot of fun but you know
there's only so many times that you can
laugh about people being put inside the
rocks body oh yeah and then there's also
the da Vinci Code
oh boy what is this 2006 so despite
Disney reportedly offering 5 million
dollars now you can start to see why
Sony might not want to sell the webhead
for anything less than 10 it's one of
the few reliable things they have that
has the potential to make large stacks
of cash last episode we covered the ins
and outs of the different agreements
Sony and Disney have had in place over
the years so if you'd like more detail
on those check out the previous episode
but knowing those deal points consider
this spider-man far from home was under
the old agreement where Sony put up a
hundred percent of the financing of the
movie and got back 95 percent of what
those movies made with the other 5
percent going to Disney as an entry fee
to get him into the MCU
Mickey Mouse is like the highest-paid
bouncer of all time want to get into the
MCU
tell me when you can
a billion dollars the film made one
point one three billion dollars and Sony
spent 160 million to make it in total
Sony walks away with 921 million and
just as a reminder all of this is super
back in the napkin math not accounting
for how much movie theaters make weird
accounting costs etc etc entertainment
is just a weird sketchy business where
numbers can literally mean anything and
come from anywhere right I have seen
this in action all of these numbers take
it with the heaviest dose of salt you
possibly can anyway that being said had
the movie been made under the current
2019 agreement Sony would have
theoretically had to pay less to finance
movie 120 million since Disney now helps
pay for the other 25% as a result Sony
takes home 75% of the return that's
eight hundred and forty nine million in
gross for a handy little seven hundred
twenty nine million dollars in profit
less overall return under this new deal
but remember they're also having to take
on significantly less monetary risk to
make the movie forty million dollars
worth of extra risk and allow dusty it's
a win-win for them so if we assume that
that's approximately the average
earnings that they're gonna get out of a
spider-man movie Sony now has to decide
would they rather produce seven films
under their current arrangement with
Disney to try and earn themselves that
five billion dollars that was offered
while still retaining the film rights to
themselves or would they rather take the
easy paycheck of five billion dollars
right on the mouse's hands and in the
process lose the spider-man film rights
making seven hit movies is a lot to
accomplish especially when every other
spider-man story seems to peter out
after its third entry get it peter out
Peter Parker out but seriously that's a
really hard number to hit but then again
you have far from homes amazing
reception and super exciting cliffhanger
venom as its own surprise hit due for
its sequel and a follow-up to spider
verse so all told the franchise is in a
really great place
spider-man is stronger than he's ever
been right now it seems like it's a
pretty easy call Sony should keep the
film rights and keep raking in that
sweet sweet Spider dough for another
decade but all of that's assuming that
Sony themselves will be in existence for
years and years to come
haha and that is the twist my friends
rumor has it
Apple is seriously thinking of acquiring
Sony in the near future and those rumors
just won't go away and see this is where
it gets juicy because if Sony sells then
spider-man's film rights automatically
revert back to Marvel which Disney now
owns that's right Disney would get the
spider-man film rights for free if Sony
winds up getting wrong so basically it's
a white-collar game of chicken should
Disney pay anything to get the rights
when they might simply get them for free
or should they hedge their bets and just
buy it to be safe should Sony sell the
rights to their cash cow because they
plan to reject Apple's advances or
should they sell the spider-man rights
and pocket a cool five billion before
Apple buys them outright anyway so here
we see why Disney may be less eager to
pay Sony's ten billion dollar price tag
even though Disney could afford it and
would likely recoup that investment
paying 10 billion dollars for the
spider-man universe wouldn't be the
dumbest thing Disney could do but paying
10 billion dollars when they could have
paid zero dollars for it certainly would
be this is game theory at play in the
real world here folks I am so excited
because this one calls for a good old
2x2 matrix otherwise known as a payoff
matrix now if you're unfamiliar game
theory often uses matrices like these to
help identify optimal strategies the
most famous one is the prisoner's
dilemma which is usually done with
criminals and suspects but I actually
prefer the other example of the British
gameshow Golden Balls which is not only
a hilarious name but also has incredibly
simple but compelling strategy at play
you see two players work together
throughout the game to rack up a big
cash pot but whether they get to walk
away with any of that money ultimately
depends on one final decision they can
either choose to take it all or split
the pot with their partner if they both
choose to split the pot well they both
win 50% of the day's earnings if one
chooses to take it all and the other
player chooses to split then the person
who took it all wins everything and the
other player wins nothing just for being
a good person and if they both choose to
be greedy and want to take it all they
both win nothing and the balls are that
much bigger and more golden in the next
episode so now let's give it a spin with
our Disney Soni scenario let's assume
that Disney only has two options on the
table either buy the rights for
million dollar price tag that Sony wants
or waded out with their current deal
Sony meanwhile will either get acquired
by Apple or not for our purposes we'll
assume Disney has no idea what Apple
plans do so this in turn sets up our two
by two matrix
Disney pay ten billion dollars are not
Sony get acquired or not
so now let's focus on the Disney payoffs
for Disney the absolute best outcome is
to pay nothing
Sony sells to Apple and Disney just
inherits the spider-man rights for free
so if Disney waits and Sony gets bought
Disney basically gets 10 billion dollars
for free so we're gonna give this
scenario a value of plus 10 for Disney
the absolute worst outcome for Disney
would be to pay the 10 billion dollars
for the rights only to then have Sony
get acquired by Apple at which point
they would have paid for something that
they could have gotten for free so we're
gonna give that scenario a minus 10 to
Disney what if Disney pays but Sony
doesn't get acquired well that's just
kind of a nothing lost nothing game
scenario for both parties Disney pays a
little more than they wanted to but
we'll probably make that price up in
time Sony gets what they believe to be a
fair price for their assets so we're
gonna give that 1 0-0 for both sides
probably more accurately a minus 1 for
Disney because they pay more than they
wanted and a plus 1 for Sony since
they're probably charging a bit of a
high price tag but first simplicity
let's say zero-zero
finally if both Disney and Sony simply
stay put in their current 2019 agreement
we're gonna call that a plus 3 for
Disney though they get less creative
control and less money than they me like
they're gonna make money and get to use
spider-man in the MCU mostly positive so
that's the Disney side of the matrix now
let's talk about Sony the best case
scenario for Sony is to pull a fast one
on Disney they sell the rights to
spider-man for 10 billion dollars right
before Apple acquires um it's like
finding a wallet with 10 billion dollars
in it so that scenario is a big plus 10
for Sony worst case for Sony would be to
not sell the rights at all and then get
acquired they'd be getting nothing for
something they themselves had valued at
10 billion dollars and that they could
have very easily sold the Disney for at
least 5 billion so that to Sony is gonna
be a minus 10 scenario finally if Sony
can manage to continue on with their
current arrangement with Disney that's a
small positive again I'd say like a plus
3 or a plus 5 they hold on to their
biggest franchise they continue making
good money off of it plus the film
the spider-man could very well continue
to increase in value in the mean time so
with our matrix now filled in what does
it tell us well we shouldn't read too
much into Sony's options since the
studio may not have much say in whether
Apple acquires them or not that's to say
the massive Apple Sony deal is probably
gonna happen or not regardless of
whether spider-man's measly little film
rights get sold off Apple just probably
doesn't care he's not getting those film
rights either way by the nature of the
contract it always is gonna revert back
to Marvel but a clear dominant strategy
does emerge for Disney no matter what
happens to Sony if Disney waits Disney
wins best case they wait and land a 10
when Sony gets acquired worst case Sony
doesn't get bought and Disney still
lands a plus 3 which is the second-best
option for them on the entire matrix
so while spider-man's movie rights may
very well be worth the 10 billion dollar
price tag that Sony seems to believe
it's pretty clear that Disney won't be
paying that price Sony's uncertain
future simply puts them into week of a
negotiating position if Apple does the
quire Sony expect to see Disney and
Sony's uneasy marriage continue
indefinitely as it's mutually beneficial
to both parties to keep Sony's movies
linked to the MCU but if the Apple
conversations do start getting really
serious expect to see a lot of news
about Sony shopping the spider-man film
rights around in a last-ditch effort to
get something for their property and
when that happens expect Disney to wind
up being the highest bidder taking the
movie rights for far less than 10
billion dollars and continuing their
unstoppable march towards world
domination
so is Spiderman worth paying 10 billion
dollars for well we concluded last time
that on paper yes was yes but in
practice the machinations of big
business actually say no Disney
shouldn't buy but hey that's just a
theory
[Music]
subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe
subscribe subscribe to film theory